I'm your host of the Dean show and we
want to encourage everybody to tune in
every week and we want to encourage
everybody to share our shows with the
world share with your neighbor share
with your colleagues at work your
friends your best friends and our
brothers in humanity who don't know many
the purpose of life and if you figured
out the purpose of life you figured out
the antidote for all the social ills and
Islam is that antidote that brings peace
and happiness and helps people to become
the best people but if you're not doing
the Dawa you're not sharing this message
then you're not doing your job and this
is what the show is all about gonna give
you some tips on how you can answer some
of the tough questions out there people
think that Islam oppresses women people
think that Islam is about violence and
terrorizing people so we're going to be
talking about the obligation of relaying
this message of calling people to only
worship the Creator not his creation
establish what God has told you to do in
your life and there's nothing but good
it's the true purpose of life we're
gonna be talking about this and why you
need to be doing it it's an obligation
it's a duty and then some of the tough
questions that might come your way the
false fallacies clearing them out of the
way so you can deliver the true message
of the pure monotheism of Islam and then
people can be successful and have
paradise in the next life and have the
avoidance of the Hellfire in the next
also and we'll be right back to talk
about this and more here on the Dean
show this is the theme
this is the thesis but angel
Salaam alaikum peace be with our alaikum
as-salaam wa time Allah hear what God is
being to YouTube now we're here with the
president the IR EF for people who don't
know much about you they can go to your
own personal section at the Deen show
calm that's where we have the previous
shows that we've done and we'll discuss
many topics and today I want to talk
about the obligation of calling people
to purpose of life purpose of life not
according to what me and you we discuss
here and we conjure up something and say
hey this what you guys should be doing
but it's something a message that was
sent throughout time through all the
messengers of God and it's something
from the divine from the crater and the
Muslims those who have submitted to the
one God many of them they're not sharing
the message with the people they don't
feel it's an obligation they feel like
you know what I'm not intelligent enough
in the Deen I don't have a month as much
knowledge in the Dean or they feel like
you know what I'll just amplified in my
character which is good and they don't
open their mouths and they'll study all
the other sciences the world but they
don't study their religion and now
someone throws a false allegation Islam
oppresses women Islam is barbaric and
they're like oh man they changed their
name from Mohammed mo Fatima to Azima or
whatever and now they just go on life
and they don't do what a lot of home to
do the duty of Dawa what do you guys say
yeah much Oh God Jekel affair I would
like to begin with honda lillahi rabbil
alameen wa sallahu wa sallam ala
rasoolillah Karim Allah Allah he was
having as mine I'm a baaad audhu billahi
min ash-shaitani rajeem all in kana a
become a Burnout kun da equinox logical
but a shear otaku but humble unix tariff
- moo-ha-ha
una casa da ha a Misaki no tardone aha
aha by lake wa min allahi what a Sulha
he what jihad infeasibility Vitara Basu
piety Allahu alayhi wa lahu lahul
[ __ ] rubbish Rolly with a threeway is
silly I'm really sunny Yahoo Kohli I'm a
baaad I will come with the ID and all my
dear respectable viewers with Islamic
greetings
assalamu alaikum where i not only over
cuddle meaning may the peace mercy and
blessings for mighty god allah subhanaw
taala be on all of you he has a very
important topic
you said Dawa what is Dawa Dawa is an
Arabic word which means to invite in the
literal meaning it would mean an
invitation but when it comes with Islam
getting attached to that word when the
word gets attached to Islam to Quran to
Hadees then Dawa would basically mean
inviting the non-muslims to Islam and of
course if the Muslims were wrongly
practicing Islam if you correct them
according to the Quran and the Sunnah
that can also be included into Dhamma
but main Dawa Dawa actually means
inviting the non-muslims to Islam and
what is the obligation about that on
every Muslim man and woman I would
reiterate many people think let the
women sit at home let the Muslim women
forget on this world now Dawa is an
obligation upon every Muslim man and
woman every Muslim man every Muslim
woman have to make it their primary
purpose of life the most important
reason to live in this world as a Muslim
to give the invitation of Islam to the
non-muslims around them the men need to
make it their primary job muslim women
need to make it their primary job
inviting the non-muslims to islam that
is their primary purpose of the life if
you read the glorious quran you will not
find a single ayat in the Quran where
Allah said to prophet muhammad
sallallahu taala
that oh prophet muhammad salallahu
alaihe salam if you do not perform fight
is allah if you do not pay the card if
you do not do Hajj if you do not do
ombres if you do not do deal justly with
your wives it
you are not good to your neighbors Allah
didn't mention any of these things to
say if you didn't do any of these any of
these things or any one of them you I
have not fulfilled the messenger world
but there is an ayat in the Quran you
believe me easy reference to remember I
tell in the public talks to the audience
to memorize this reference it's a very
easy reference to remember surah maidah
is the fifth surah of the Quran surah
number 5 at number 67 numerically you
see fifth surah 67th I had five six
seven come together fifth surah 67th
ayat what is the ayat Allah says yeah
you are a soul oh you prophets Allah
Allah Allah as Salam o you messenger
sallallaahu less alarmed or you
messenger peace be upon you
yeah your Rasul believe mouths aligned I
come Arabic do the propagation of what
has been revealed to you from your god
propagated preached it
priscila ties it promoted proclaim it
reach out with it to the mankind but
like Mozilla like Amira big for Alam
tough al if you do not do that imagine
what I said the ayat no in the quran
ever says if you do not perform salah if
you do not give the zakah no no nothing
like that
but this ayah says if you do not do this
file am tough only if you do not do the
job of propagating this message to the
mankind for in length of all baba left
or is allah then you have not fulfilled
your mess in the hood allah well-loved
we are SEMA come in on us if you fear
anyone amongst the mankind that they can
create problems for you if you reach out
to them with the message of the Quran
with the message of this love
propagating this message if you fear
anyone in the world Allah will protect
you from them that is the promise of
Allah subhana Allah this was the main
mission of prophet muhammad sallallahu
wasallam being sent as a messenger and
that is the message to entire mankind
and Allah is making sure that every
Muslim does that job Allah says in Ali
Imran surah number 3 as number 110 kun
button you are the best of the people
when Allah said couldn't O'Hara umma Tim
Allah included in the MOT the Muslim men
and the Muslim women why am i again and
again saying there are some shameless
and rubbish people who claim themselves
to be Muslim scholars unfortunately they
claim they are not honest scholars they
trying to tell to the people a Muslim
woman need not do Dawa no every Muslim
man and woman has to do Dawa and Allah
says come to Muhammad in critical in
mass you are the best of the opah simple
Arabic that includes the Muslim men and
the women you are the best of the Ummah
evolved for the mankind brought out to
work for the mankind what Tom aru Nabil
Marouf you invite them to the good and
of all the good things that we do the
most important good or the bestest to
believe in Allah subhana Allah is the
only one God Tom are you Nabil Maru
fatin halal moon car and you stop the
mankind from doing evil and of all the
evil in the earth of all the evil the
dirtiest of all is commiting Shilka with
allah is associating partner with allah
allah says you are the best of the
people because you invite the mankind to
allah
you forbid them from the evil you invite
them to the good but told me no Nabil
and you also believe in Allah subhana
Allah and I had continues well Amin al
khattab Ilocano heroin it would have
been very good for the Jews and the
Christians had day 2 also believed in
this mean human movie Luna of then there
are a few who are believers who moon but
most of them are perverted transgressors
meaning they know that religion is
important Allah is the god Mohamed Salah
some is truly the messenger but yet they
are perverted transgressors
so it is our duty to invite these people
to Islam the word hollow in the Quran
comes for about 331 times meaning hollow
Arabic what kala means they say they say
they say and the word cool
meaning you say it also occurs about 331
times Allah is saying go and tell them
go and tell them cool oh well yeah you
Hulk off a road say to them Allah is the
only one say to them or you disbelievers
lob to Metabo dune
I do not worship what you worship
messages to be given to them Coolio
al-khattab oh you people of the book or
you Jews and the Christians so
everywhere the Quran is inviting the
Muslims to go and do da WA and I began
my talk by reciting one of the most
militant ayat of the Quran from surah
Tauba surah number 9 at number 24 and
again I am saying some shameless
interpreters unfortunately in the Muslim
mother say this ayat is not for da this
ayah does not include the women to do
Dawa this ad does not include the
children to do da WA no no no nobody
said that the top mufasa the Quran if
the castle or if a Nia the great people
they said every Muslim Ummah thei of
Prophet Muhammad SAW Salam is bound to
do Dawa and what is the ayat Allah Akbar
if you read surah Tauba surround number
9 it's the only surah that does not
begin with the beautiful formula
bismillahirrahmanirrahim Allah is angry
from ayat number one to add number 22
upon the non-muslims of the time of
Prophet Mohammed of the Makkah city who
broke a treaty with Prophet Muhammad SAW
salam who breached a treaty Allah is
very angry with them Allah says wage a
war against those who would deceit you
and then from ayat number 23 till the
end of the surah allah is extremely
angry with muslims who do not practice
Islam with Muslim men and women who do
not strive in the way of Allah who do
not do Bauer who do not go to the
non-muslims to educate them about Islam
Allah is angry with them Allah is saying
these people who do not practice Islam
or prophet in surah Tauba surah number
nine at number 80 Allah says these
Muslims if you pray who do not practice
Islam perfectly if you pray for their
forgiveness a 70 times Allah is not
going to forgive them so this ayat if
you read Allah says well say to them
what is the ayat in at number 24 so
retama surah number 9
all say to them a prophet say to whom
not the non-muslims to us muslims are
life saying say to these muslims
in cana about whom whether it be your
father or your mother what about now
come your sons or your daughters like
one of them your brothers or your
sisters welcome your spouse's or your
husband's well she wrote whom you are
related
your friends bottom balloon experiment
that you have amassed for yourself
deposited for yourself in your own
deposits of the banks but the durante
una Casa de ha or the businesses that
you deal in or the jobs that you do the
government jobs the private jobs the
private businesses from misaki north or
dona or the homes in which you delight
to live or the countries in which you
love to live he ate things Allah said
your mother and your father your
children your brothers or your sisters
your husbands or your wives your
relatives or your friends the wealth
that you have amassed for yourself your
businesses your homes or your countries
where you love to live if you think
these eight things if you love these
eight things a hub mind I could move a
hub by local min allahi but as soon as
he what jihad in feasibility if you love
these eight things more than Allah more
than most also a mind doing jihad in the
way of Allah and believe me I'm in the
United States of America
when I say jihad I don't mean bombing
the Twin Towers no no when Allah says
jihad Allah means jihad when there is no
war the jihad is to go to the people and
preach Islam to talk to them about Islam
this is jihad in Islam jihad means it's
from the root word jihad to strive for
the good to strive against the evil that
you do by educating and at times when it
is required when a government of the
country of a Muslim country it has the
right to involve not every any
individual Muslim not a group of Muslims
coming together and deciding let's go
and bomb blast
let's go and commit a suicide bomb blast
no no not this way in a proper way when
the governments involved when there is a
United Muslim leader who takes the
decision that now it's time that we
fight a war against the evil then it's
okay but otherwise the jihad is to
propagate islam through the quran allah
says in surah Furqan so write number 25
at number 62
do jihad l Kabira meaning do the great
jihad using the Quran that is the top
seed of the ayat so Allah says if you
love these eight things your father and
your mother your children your brothers
and your sisters your wives or your
husband's your relatives or your friends
your wealth that you have amassed your
businesses in
if you deal your homes in which or the
countries in which you love to live if
you love these e38 things more than a
lamas Aslam and doing jihad in the way
of a life striving in the way of Allah
Fattah rabisu then wait it's a warning
wait for what died at the Alabi
Emeryville all I had no father came
unless Allah brings a severe punishment
upon you and Allah does not guide a
perverted transgressor
we're gonna we're gonna take a break and
we right back with more Today Show
outside of this name you can not be a
Muslim intended our faith to believe in
and love Jesus Christ why is it then
when it comes to one of the most
important decisions in life literally
abuse ourselves it's not that the main
thing we're looking for is to see what
type of money he has so that he can
treat my daughter like a princess back
here on the Deen show with the president
of the IR EF and we're talking about the
obligation the duty of Dawa there's a
verse in the Quran maybe you can also
expound on this in the surah al-baqarah
where Allah the Almighty is also talking
about those who they conceal the
knowledge after it's been made clear to
them so if you already know that look
Islam is the truth Islam provides the
proof it's a solution for all the social
ills it tells people what the purpose of
life is it talks about what they're gone
when they die what they need to be doing
in this life so they can be successful
and have paradise in the nest and you're
holding his back that Allah curse will
curse you and the angels will curse you
and those who curse it is true very true
of course see when allah subhanaw taala
gave the quran to prophet muhammed
sallalahu sallam and the ayat i read
from surah - row number five at number
67 where allah made it clear if you do
not propagate this message then prophet
you have not completed your messenger
would you have not been honest to your
messenger hood imagine the seriousness
of allah subhanaw taala asking Moses on
to convey the message because all the
messages that came before the Quran like
Torah the zaboor the injeel
but made only for the Bani Israel they
were not meant for the mankind they were
meant only for the children of Israel if
you read the Torah you read the Subura
injeel
you see Jesus Christ my peace be upon
him in the Gospel of Matthew chapter
number 5 verse number 17 he says very
clearly that I have not come to break
the law or the prophets have come to
fulfill meaning the Torah if you read
the Gospel of Matthew chapter number 10
verse number five and six he is
instructing his disciples not to go into
the entire world but go only to the lost
sheep of the house of Israel
so these messages that came before Quran
were only for the people of the time and
for that particular time period only to
that nation for those prophets but Allah
sent Muhammad sallallaahu salam as a
messenger to the entire universe if you
reach for a ambience for a number 21 at
number one and 7 Allah said what
Marcella Tyler Hamilton al-amin we sent
you not but as a mercy to the whole of
the universe if you read
so it's Abbas remember 34 Athol between
the eighth Allah said that Prophet
Muhammad SAW Salam o ma arsalnaka illa
calf at Elena's he sent you not but to
the mankind Allah bashira 1a0 as giving
them glad tidings and warning them but
most of them mankind understand this not
then if you read the Quran Allah says in
surah bakra surah number two and number
185 shahru ramadana alladhi unzila fihi
Quran Ramadan is the month in which the
Quran was revealed coudl in nas it is a
guidance to the whole of humanity but by
Anatomy know who novel for Han it's a
clear guidance and a criterion if for
Han to judge between right and the wrong
when Allah said to the whole mankind
then who are the believers in the quran
we muslims of the believer in the quran
now how will the remaining mankind know
about it so it is the duty who had
believed in it
to propagate it to other others the
Prophet SAW Allah Islam in a hadith
since Al Bukhari volume number 4 hadith
number 667 in the old edition he said
ballyhoo only voila ayah if you know one
thing about me convey to others there
are some Muslims who give an excuse well
I don't have the knowledge how can I
give about it the Prophet is making you
eligible every Muslim man and woman the
Prophet is saying if you know one thing
conveyed a Muslim cannot be a Muslim
unless he knows
things minimum if he doesn't know these
three things he is a non-muslim to
become a Muslim he has to know and
believe in these three things the first
is he has to know Allah is the only one
god second he has to know that domicile
is the last and final nabi and Russell
the last and final prophet and Messenger
of Allah subhana Allah the third thing
he has to know that Ferran is the
hundred percent verbatim word of Allah
subhana Allah
it is predicted by Allah no changes have
occurred innate and till Yama it is the
book of guidance to the whole mankind no
other book will come if he doesn't know
these things
he's a non-muslim then he has to know
and the Prophet is saying you know one
thing propagated to others the five
pillars of Islam Sahih al-bukhari volume
number one hadith number eight cold
addition hadith number seven the Prophet
said buñuel is Lama Allah comes in Islam
is based on five fundamentals Shahada
Cannell ilaha illallah muhammad rasool
allah you see what is the first
principle Shahada 'then so muslims
translated read lila la mama no no the
Hadees is Shahada Arabic word Shahada
means to bear witness
what does bear witness mean to those who
do not know you have to bear witness in
the court of law witness comes because
the judge who is going to give the
judgment the judge does not know what
judgment he has to give because he was
not there at the scene of the crime or
the scene of the issue so the witness
the witness comes and says I am the
witness to this issue we Muslims have
been made the witness in the Quran in
surah baqara surah number two and number
143
in surah Hajj surah number 22 is number
78 Allah said we are the witness to the
mankind and the Prophet is saying you
bear the witness give the witness to
them what witness that there is no God
except Allah and Muhammad is the
Messenger of Allah Allah is a meaning of
the five pillars Shahada Salah psalms
zakat and Hajj the very first pillar of
Islam is Dawa to the non-muslims it is
more important than Salah some zakat and
Hajj
unfortunately we Muslims are doing it
very sad part I'm going to take a break
and we'll be back to wrap it up here on
the deed show
you the truth and the attribute oh the
one who created you that he's one and
alone running this universe that he
doesn't become born he doesn't die he
doesn't eat then go to the bathroom this
is not God problem yeah it's this it
doesn't make sense
who was Jesus worshiping Jesus is
recorded in the Gospels despite all of
the other issues about the Gospels we
put those aside with the Saints
mentioned there with Jesus back here on
the Deen show wrapping up we only got a
few more minutes and I just want to ask
you a few more questions you mentioned
that that that Taoism is more important
than you mentioned is that true than
prayer than fasting and all yeah because
I give the evidence then the prophets
awesome in the first pillar of Islam is
that shahadat on and Lyla Halle Barry
Byck what Shahada is to bear witness to
others not I was everything to be the
first thing the prophets say without
acknowledging that there is no god but
the one God there's no deity worthy of
worship except Allah yes is the first
pillar of Islam jihad about this giving
witness about this so it's very well
understood that downward to non-muslims
is more important than philosophical
knowledge
yeah what about the woman she might say
no so it's my obligation of Dawa she
would think that okay then how do I go
up to a man and give him dower very
important question yes and I said women
have to do Dawa the most important thing
that women should remember is a woman
will do Dawa only amongst the women
unless when it is very important and
there is no other solution left that
accept she has to for a time temporarily
once or twice interact with with a man
she would just interact and immediately
try to guide the man to the Muslim dice
the Muslim men who are the dice and the
Muslim man would do the same thing when
he is doing Dawa he cannot do it
individually to a woman if he feels
there is a woman who is in need here we
try to guide that woman to the Muslim
women to understand it but a Muslim
woman cannot be stopped saying no no you
sit at home do the homework you don't
come out you shouldn't come out this is
all rubbish so it is every man and woman
need to do it clarify them yes the woman
should be very yeah the reason for that
is if you read the Quran in surrender
also remember
sixteen at number 97 in surah ahzaab so
remember 33 at number 35 Allah subhana
WA Ta'ala has given conditions that
anybody who does a good deeds whether
man or woman they will get the great
reward human mumineen one of the omen
moment in she has restless a lot of some
she said the Quran speaks so much about
the favors of the men but what about the
women Allah revealed today as absolute
number 33 I have number 35 to control
the women and say in malmo slay me novel
Muslim advisory that is a Muslim man or
a woman moment man or a woman a woman
ten categories of good men and good
women are given in the Quran in surah
ahzaab surah number 33 at number 35
where Allah said both of them will get
the equal reward in general yeah we got
to keep these short now we're out of
time to tell us but just just a couple
more things really in brief tell us for
the individual because I said we're
going to give some some tips and the
time is so short I'm sure you can
elaborate on this for so long for the
people who are out there and they are
very timid because things allegations
are thrown at them we can just give one
practical example they say for the woman
but say another woman comes and says
look it's Lama presses woman and now
she's like I only wear this because of
my parents so this is a perfect
opportunity to give downward to clear up
that's all such and explain its nature
give us a practice sample one minute one
minute
absolutely you see one thing in Hinduism
- in Hinduism Hindu as a religion if you
read a liquid book number 18 number 33
verse number 19 it commands the women in
Hinduism to bring their feets closer to
look down and to cover themselves from
the head to the toe if you read the
Bible the Bible says in the book of
Deuteronomy chapter number 22 verse
number 5 that a woman shall not dress
like a man a man shall not dress like a
woman and if you see the Jewish women
the religious Jews women they look so
close to the Muslim women they are
always covered it's very nice to see
they are dressed very modestly if you
look at the portraits of mother Mary she
is never dressed like a Western woman of
the modern time in a bikini or in skirts
or minis she is dressed completely like
a Muslim woman if you look at the nuns
going to the church you will find them
covered from the head to the toe back in
India in my country mother Teresa she
won the Nobel Prize and
she was always covered from the head to
the toe when the non-muslim women
covered from the head to the toe they
become religious woman women
nothing is suppression they are very God
pious women Muslim women when they're
doing problem comes now and the cycle is
psycho a psychiatrist and a psychologist
they say the dress code it affects the
behavior of the opposite sex towards the
one who is wearing the dress
unfortunately when the Western women
started wearing less clothes the rate of
crime against the women increased in
these countries if you analyze the
statistics unfortunately I am very I
really feel very happy that America is a
country where honest statistics are put
forward for academic research if you
read the statistic for the year 2000 in
America by the National Crime
Victimization survey Bureau report
Bureau of Justice Department by the US
State Department it says every two
minute in the US a woman was raped can
you imagine that
in 2001 the same National Crime
Victimization survey reported says
84,000 women were raped in one year
which is about 230 women being raped per
day can you imagine that figure so
mostly the secateurs feel that this is
happening because of an improper dress
code that is one of the reason I'm not
saying psychologists are saying yes I'm
not saying not all psychologists that is
how its popular but of course I just
could place a person might say all the
women who don't wear proper dress are
Errol trade I don't mean to say that I
never say that every woman who wears a
dress which is less is an immodest woman
completely but the dress code affects
the opposite sex it can attract and
under why uninvited guests towards you
in a wrong sense so it's better to
murders because every religion is
promoting a modest dress code you see
the crime rate goes down when the women
are properly dressed up it's not
separation Muslim women when they wear
the hijab nobody forces them they read
the Quran they understand it Allah said
in surah a news for a number 24
at number 30 Allah said to the man to
lower the gates and guard their modesty
then in ayat number 31 Allah said in
surah Newsarama 24 that the woman shall
cover her bosoms shall not show off the
beauty that appear
except they're off and she shall not go
out without covering herself if you read
surah ahzaab so remember 33 as number 59
Allah says o prophet Moses lump say to
your wives to your daughters and the
believing women to cover themselves from
the head to the toe Jill Bob is the
Arabic word used Jill bapnese to cover
from the head to the toe so some people
some Muslim women also sometimes ask and
fortunately the feminist Muslim women
they ask you see very difficult doesn't
come in the Quran
Jill Bob is a severe category of hijab
Jill Bob needs to cover from the head to
the toe and it by default includes the
hijab and Jill Bob means to cover the
dress you have already worn and this is
a natural phenomena if they do it it's
for the betterment it's there in every
religion it's not just that Islam says
so and Islam never put it on a woman as
I said in fact his Quran became the
first book on the face of the earth
religiously which gave rights to
inheritance to the women if you read
surah nisa surah number 4 and verse 7 to
9 I had them at 11 to 13 at number 33 of
surah nisa you will find that Allah gave
rights of inheritance to the women which
were never there in any religion before
if you read the Bible in the Book of
Leviticus chapter number 12 verse number
one to five it says
if a girl child is born the mother is
impure for 14 days if a boy child is
born only for seven days unscientific
and degradation of women book of Genesis
chapter number three verse number 16 it
says that the labor pain of the
delivering mother is a punishment to her
from the God for what Eve did in the
original sin degradation of women if you
read The Book of Numbers chapter number
five verse number eleven to verse number
thirty-one it bitter what a test is
given that if a husband has a doubt upon
his wife on her chastity he would take
her to the priest the priest would bring
some water dip the woman in it and if
the woman the water doesn't become
bitter
she is fine unscientific test bigger
addition of women first Corinthians
chapter number 11 verse number five and
six of the Bible in the New Testament it
says if the woman does not want her hair
on the head to be Shoval off she feels
ashamed of that let her keep her hair
covered when worship
the God so when worshipping the God you
want to be covered his lamb says Muslim
woman when she is walking on the road in
the right way she is worshiping the God
worshipping of God in Islam is not in
the Muslim alone every action that a
Muslim and a man and woman does
according to Quran and Sunnah is
worshiping Allah subhana Allah by
default and if you read 2nd Timothy
chapter number 2 verse number 12 to 14
it says a woman shall not dress in
modestly shall not wear ornaments to
show off you see so close to Islam yeah
so close to Islam so we gotta gain the
knowledge and I would like to put one
statement Eddie very important statement
when V Muslims are saying wear hijab we
are not trying to be anti West we are
not anti West we are trying to tell the
Western people you're women we respect
them like our sisters we don't want the
criminals in the society to wrongly
feast at your sister who is a sister to
us also being the children of Adam and
Eve thank you very much for out of time
we got to go
assalamu alaikum what I'm looking like
Oh God thank you God Almighty the
creator Allah reward you and thank you
for tuning in to another episode of Deen
show you got a gained a knowledge you
got to sit and take the time you should
be the best at whatever you do but don't
neglect your duty in life and that Duty
comes from the owner of life the one God
the creator of all that exists so he
calls us to share the purpose of life
with mankind you saw we just gave you
one example how easy it is to clear this
false information is out there and one
example was about the oppression of
women easily explained and easily the
truth is made clear and then you can go
ahead and explain the pure monotheism of
Islam the day of judgment accountability
in this life the reward of paradise
Hellfire and the simple message of Islam
to worship the one creator and not his
creature is not his creation and to do
good deeds we'll see you next time
inshallah God willing until then peace
be unto you